ahora quiero utilizar un diodo en este
circuito y veremos cómo resolver los
circuitos que tengan estos elementos no
lineales tengo este circuito con su
batería su resistencia y un diodo
en nuestro circuito vamos a tener una
resistencia de 330 oms
y haremos a esta batería de tres pollos
qué equivale a dos pilas doble a
aproximadamente y lo que queremos es
encontrar cuánta corriente fluye en este
circuito déjame etiquetar a los voltajes
a través de nuestros componentes tenemos
a pepe que es este voltaje de aquí
y tenemos a de r
qué es el voltaje en la resistencia este
voltaje de aquí ahora te mostraré una
gráfica de la curva y b de nuestro diodo
vemos aquí que el voltaje está alrededor
de 0.7 volts la corriente se eleva
rápidamente cuando se mantiene este 0.7
a través del diodo y empecemos con las
herramientas que siempre tenemos
intentemos escribir algunas leyes de
corriente para estas dos variables para
el diodo escribimos una ley de corriente
que se ve de esta manera la corriente es
igual a s
x ala
ve sobre acá
- 1
esa es la característica y ve para el
diodo dónde está de aquí es de diodo
y la ecuación correspondiente para la
resistencia es
igual al voltaje de la resistencia sobre
330 oms
esto es simplemente la ley de ohm para
la resistencia y la y en ambos casos es
esta y de aquí si quisiera podría
igualar estas dos expresiones y resolver
de alguna manera para bb br pero en vez
de eso vamos a resolverlo graficando
encontraremos la respuesta a través de
un método gráfico aquí está la gráfica
del diodo y este es el eje de pepe y acá
arriba está la aic
y ahora lo que quiero hacer es graficar
también la curva para la resistencia
quiero graficar la curva y ve en la
misma gráfica
en esta expresión tengo a br en lugar de
bebé así que déjame ver si puedo
trabajar con b&r aquí déjame intentar
obtener a pr en términos de bebé
puedo decir que pr es igual a 3 volts
menos bebé y pongamos esto dentro de
esta expresión de y por lo que la
expresión de la ley de ohm ahora es i
igual a br se reemplaza por 3 - p p todo
dividido entre 330
y trabajemos con esto aún más
es igual a 3
sobre 330
- dt
sobre 303
y esto empieza a verse como la ecuación
de una línea
déjame escribir esto para reconocerlo
como la ecuación de una línea
- dt sobre 330
+ 3 sobre 330 son 9.000 amperes
esta es la ecuación de una línea y la
pendiente está aquí es menos verde sobre
330 y la intersección con d es igual a
9000 jumpers veamos si podemos graficar
esta línea está de hecho es llamada
recta
es solo un apodo para este tipo de
expresión que obtienes cuando tienes a
una resistencia conectada a una fuente
de poder fija arriba y la resistencia
cuelga de ella obtienes esta ecuación
característica de la línea que tiene una
pendiente negativa lo que es muy
distintivo
veamos si podemos graficar esta línea
bueno es una línea por lo que lo único
que tenemos que hacer es encontrar dos
puntos de la línea y seremos capaces de
dibujar la sía goave de igual a cero
entonces
y es igual a 9000 amperes aquí está bebé
igual a 0 y llegará hasta 9.000 amperes
ese es un punto en la línea y qué más
puedo igualar a cero puedo igualar a
cero lo que significa que estoy en el
eje del voltaje y lo que haré ahora es
ver mi circuito y resolverlo mentalmente
estoy igualando y a cero si es igual a
cero significa que no hay corriente en
esta resistencia lo que significa que no
hay caída de voltaje a través de esta
resistencia y eso significa que este
voltaje de aquí es el mismo que este
voltaje de aquí
y conozco el voltaje aquí el voltaje
aquí es de tres poles lo que significa
que el voltaje acá es de 3 volts y eso
es porque sé que la corriente es 0
continuamos poniendo ese punto en la
línea cuando y es 0 b es igual a
botox
por lo que tenemos otro punto de la
línea ahora tenemos dos puntos y podemos
dibujar una línea entre ellos
esta manera
y lo que hemos dibujado en la recta de
carga para esta resistencia de 330 ops
recuerda que aquí abajo dijimos que
pudimos haber resuelto esto igualando
las dos es y eso es básicamente donde
estas dos líneas se intersecta se
intersectan justo aquí esa es la
solución de nuestro problema este punto
de intersección es una solución es donde
la corriente de la resistencia y la del
diodo son iguales es ese punto de ahí y
entonces puedo leer mi respuesta ahí
0.7 volts
la corriente aquí arriba si leo el valor
de la corriente está alrededor de 6.8
mili amperes y hemos resuelto nuestro
circuito
utilizando una técnica gráfica
lo que dice es déjame borrar esto un
poco para hacerlo más claro déjame
quitar estas dos
os hace aquí sólo hablábamos de la recta
de carga de la resistencia y ahora para
nuestra solución tenemos que y es igual
a 6.8 william pérez
de la bebé el yodo equivale a 0.7 ports
así es como haces una solución gráfica
con un diodo